I started using tik-tok during
quarantine and there's a word I can use
to describe it that I honestly wouldn't
use to describe any other social media I
use right now it's delightful just found
this stick that sounds really nice when
you drop it listen and then nice if you
use tick-tock long enough you'll
probably experience something I've
experienced multiple times now on your
for you page tick tocks personalise feed
of videos that thinks you'll like a
video will pop up containing a joke or
reference or on a topic that seems
almost impossibly specific to you and
your life quick name your favorite song
did you know that's actually incorrect
you see your favorite song is actually
Jack Johnson's hit single featured in
the Curious George movie you just forgot
about it so specific you might think
that nobody else would have gotten that
joke or that tick tock might be spying
on you one thing about being an adult
that no one ever talks about is how much
time you spend debating with yourself
whether to keep a cardboard box or not
and not this experience itself but the
reason it happens is I think a big part
of why tick tock is winning what I want
to talk about in this video thanks to
audible for sponsoring this video get a
free audiobook when you go to
audible.com slash Thomas flight on the
surface tick tock is just a platform
that allows you to share videos up to
one minute in length but I think what
really makes the app powerful is a
little less visible it's hard to pitch
people on why they might like to [ __ ]
because if you're like I was six months
ago you probably think it looks mostly
like this
[Music]
and while viral dances are an undeniably
large part of tick-tocks culture it can
be so much more than that like every
social media platform everyone's feed
looks a little bit different mine looks
something like this
people seem to think that cucumbers are
the easiest thing to pickle and I don't
blame you Oh God
there it is can you see me how you guys
holding up hold it up hold it I don't
know starter pots come without a
drainage hole no if they power can
compare to that of the label maker by
putting green tea leaves on top of ice
cubes because like like it's obviously
this one that makes sense of course this
feed might not be that appealing to you
but if you use tick-tock you'll receive
a feed that matches your interest you
might think I'm describing how all
social media work but I used the word
receive very specifically because on
other social media platforms you tend to
build your feed what's unique about tick
tock is that the algorithm does the work
for you and it does it better than you
ever could
[Music]
online we now live in a world dominated
by algorithms gone are the days where
you simply saw the content of the people
you followed subscribe to or were
friends with in chronological order
every major social media platform uses
an algorithm to show you the content it
thinks you'll want to see or at least
content that will keep you coming back
to that platform in the age of the
algorithm tik-tok wins because in my
experience the tic-tock algorithm is the
most powerful of any social media
platform I've used most of the time you
spend on tick-tock you'll probably spend
browsing your for you page which is a
curated feed of videos from all of
tick-tock a lot of times this feed will
actually match your interests better and
serve you better content than the feed
of the people you follow this algorithm
is so good that the way of matches
people up with people like them or their
specific interests have become somewhat
of an inside joke on the platform so we
get the three keys of black lives matter
indigenous and socio anarchist tick
tocks
for lesbian tick tock to then place us
in stoner which cottage score or goth
tick tock but why is tick tocks
algorithm so robust and effective one
answer might be that they're just
developing their software better than
other people and that may be the case
but I think a significant part of the
nature of the algorithm success is tied
to the design of the platform itself on
YouTube every time you watch a video you
provide YouTube with a data point that
it can use to understand your interests
how long you watch if you skip ahead
like or comment are all aspects of that
data point that YouTube can analyze to
determine what you like so it can
recommend things to you and any well
bill algorithm more data should mean a
better algorithm if each interaction is
a data point imagine how many data
points you give Netflix for every hour
you watch Netflix you generate one or
two data points for them those data
points are all Netflix has to go on to
determine what to recommend to you for
every hour you spend on YouTube you
might generate a dozen data points but
in one hour using tick-tock where many
videos are only 15 seconds you could
easily generate over a hundred data
points in just that hour every time you
swipe on tick-tock you're feeding the
algorithm and for
about your interests this powerful
algorithm doesn't just make for a better
experience for the viewer it also makes
tick-tock and enticing place for
creators on tick-tock you don't need any
previous following friends or clout if
you have a really good piece of content
that people want to watch it has the
potential for millions of views on
tick-tock regardless of your current
following as you swipe through your 4u
page you'll occasionally come across
videos with a few likes and very little
views from a random person you've never
seen before
each tick-tock will get sent to an
initial pool of viewers if they engage
with it positively it will get sent on
to another larger pool and so on tech
not can do this because the cost for
tick-tock of recommending a piece of
content that you don't like to you is
very low if you don't like a video you
just keep swiping and at most you've
wasted a few seconds of your time on the
other hand the cost of recommending a
video you don't like is very high for
YouTube if YouTube recommends you a
video you don't like that's a whole
click and engagement wasted one of
probably only a few you'll spend on
YouTube that day if you don't like the
video you've potentially wasted minutes
and if YouTube does this enough you'll
begin to lose faith in its algorithm and
maybe start to ignore the
recommendations 1 tick-tock you can
start at zero on with one high-quality
piece of content you can end up with
millions of views another unique thing
about tick-tock is that it's a largely
clickless platform while something like
YouTube depends heavily on you seeing a
thumbnail and then clicking on it on
tick-tock you're just automatically
watching the content you get to judge
whether you want to watch it or not by
the content itself not a title and
thumbnail this new system eliminates the
clickbait issues that we have on a lot
of click based platforms there are
definitely still annoying trends that
try to game this system but the cool
thing here is that the tick-tock
algorithm can figure out you don't like
those kinds of videos and stop showing
them to you the way the algorithm works
leads me to the second reason I think
it's succeeding especially among young
people
[Music]
YouTube was a massive democratization of
video content production before YouTube
if you wanted to distribute video
content
you needed a ton of resources and
connections but even now especially
these days on YouTube it takes quite a
bit of effort and some resources to meet
the minimum standards that viewers have
for content it's still massively easier
than having a TV show but on YouTube
you'll still need to buy and set up and
use a camera microphone editing software
and probably lights in order to create
content that YouTube viewers are
actually probably going to want to watch
tic toc however almost completely
democratizes video content production
anyone who can download the app to their
phone has the tools necessary to create
a video that potentially millions of
people will watch of course tic toc
didn't invent this it's building on the
groundwork that vine Instagram and
snapchat have laid in terms of marrying
the platform itself - the tools needed
to create the content this
democratization of production alongside
the potential for growth found in the
algorithm means that the barrier to
entry for every user to becoming a
content creator is extremely low this is
Dora one of my favorite tik tok users
today we're at the garden I just thought
I would show you guys how far grown she
started out using tech talk like
everybody else but as people started
paying attention to her content and
started asking her questions she started
talking about her life as a single
mother and school teacher in Zambia
because of tick tock she was able to
raise a large amount of financial
support for her community and school
while maintaining ownership of her
narrative and story this altruistic
support was generated unmediated by a
first world humanitarian organization
that would have told her story for her
in best case scenarios like this this
democratization of the platform would
allow some voices that have been kept
out of telling their stories through
traditional means to build an audience
but another aspect of this
democratization is perhaps tic TOCs most
visible and obvious unique
characteristic a big part of production
value is music quality but on YouTube
and other platforms this can actually be
a difficult and expensive part of the
process for a lot of content creators
finding music that is high-quality that
you can use legally it takes a lot of
time or cost a lot of money and forget
using your favorite pop song that's just
not an option
Tik Tok takes young
people and content creators desire to
use music they know and love in their
content and makes that legally and
financially possible music is obviously
a huge part of memes and trends in our
culture and giving young people the only
place in the Internet where they can
legitimately use the music they love for
these purposes without the threat of
their content being taken down makes the
platform hugely appealing I think the
music element also plays a role in the
strength of the algorithm the track used
on a video is one of the elements that
Tik Tok uses to recommend that video
this allows tik toks recommendations to
be partially built around musical tastes
something that can be oddly specific and
a little esoteric and it might be part
of the reason why the algorithm can find
you content that doesn't seem related on
the surface but that you actually really
love and the tools Tik Tok gives to
creators to allow them to remix and
reuse music have unintended positive
consequences the duet feature allows
creators to respond to or comment on
other people's videos and the ability to
dub your videos with other people's
sounds creates a strong remix culture
make the film degree
vape the film degree people create a lot
of content that responds to or builds on
other people's content okay there's very
much a feeling that content creators
aren't just putting out content in their
silo but are participating in a broader
conversation on the platform so what can
we learn from all this well if I'm right
about tick-tocks strengths coming mostly
from its algorithm then we might see a
lot of platforms in the future being
designed specifically to get data from
its users so that it can build a
stronger algorithm and the platforms
that we might see most successful are
the ones that naturally provide a lot of
data points for those platforms
algorithms and better algorithms should
make for better experiences for users
and creators but for teenagers and
adults who are potentially spending
hours using this platform how much of
their world view and view of themselves
and their peers is being shaped by an
artificial intelligence tic-tac does
have an algorithm to evaluate how pretty
you are
if you spend enough time on the Chinese
deep web you can find by Dan's
documentation like this Google Translate
tells us that they are looking at the
beauty of the hottest ugliest and
average person in your video and I
wonder if the positivity comes from the
algorithm just being better at keeping
me in a bubble of people who think like
me and away from people who don't I've
seen a tendency by people my age and
older to write off tik-tok because it
just seems like something for young
people but if we do this we'll miss out
on understanding why people are enjoying
it so much and the lessons we can learn
from tech talk that will help us
understand how to build better and more
positive social media platforms in the
future thanks so much to audible for
sponsoring this video every month you
get a credit for a free audio book plus
a selection of audible originals syncing
between devices allows you to listen on
different devices and pick up where you
left off I listen to audiobooks a lot
whether it's on road trips or while I'm
doing menial video editing and audible
lets you build up a digital library of
audiobooks the audiobook I want to
recommend to you today is Neil postman's
technically Neil postman and Marshall
McLuhan have been two very influential
figures on how I
think about this stuff a Neil postman
takes a lot of Marshall McLuhan's ideas
and applies them to our modern
technological landscape in this audio
book it's a great listen if you want to
try to learn about how to look at our
modern technology landscape and the way
that it's affecting our lives you can
get this audio book or any other audio
book inaudible library for free when you
sign up for your 30 day free trial by
going to audible.com slash Thomas flight
or by texting Thomas flight to five
hundred five hundred
that's audible.com slash Thomas flight
or text thomas flight to five hundred
five hundred
thanks again so much to audible for
sponsoring this video thank you so much
for watching if you're interested in
supporting my channel directly you can
go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]